invite our candle to honor the sacred
time of mourning as we grieve the loss
of our dear
threats
this was a scene earlier tonight in
Henderson as the community poured out on
the one-year Mark of a deadly crash
killing 13-year-old Rex Patchett Rex was
walking on the sidewalk of Manion Middle
School when a speeding driver lost
control and hit him here you can see
students friends and family all showing
support the driver who hit Rex 21 year
old Jose marmalejo was sentenced to six
years in prison for that crash and since
Rex is passing the city of Henderson
approved a project to make that space
safer including a flashing light for
pedestrians